The one that occupies 70% of the planet,
the sea.
Tala this,
the cry of the expedition of 10.000,
revealing the mother of worlds,
the Mediterranean mother.
Look at her,
look at his power,
his strength.
This is the way out of nuclear power
who is in front of you.
It contains
66 times the energy needed on earth.
It is there forever,
the night,
the day,
with the movement started,
the movement of currents in the depths,
the circulation of the moon around our planet.
The sea,
the sea that begins the water cycle,
because it is of the sea that by evaporation
that will give the rain,
the rain, the rivers,
the rivers,
the water that we will consume.
All living beings on the surface of the planet
are 1 delayed reproduction of this beautiful water,
that of the sea,
justice for all of us,
1 ecology
practical and uncompromising